after a year like 2020 most of us want
to start 2021 off strong right we want
to set the tone for a positive
and healthy year so tone and sculpt
trainer danielle wilson
is here to show us the way welcome to
the show hi thank you so much for having
me
of course you look great and i know
you're joining us from chicago so first
just introduce yourself and tell us what
you do
yeah well welcome to my home this
messiah
my apartment in chicago i am a trainer
on the tone and sculpt app i've been
training for about
five years now um athlete my entire life
did gymnastics and all the way up
through college
college i actually was a cheerleader as
well and then after
college i was lucky enough to turn
my passion for activity into a career so
that kind of brings me to where we are
now beautiful i have a
special respect for female athletes i
play basketball in college so i
understand
quite not quite gymnastics though
not quite i have so much respect for you
guys um the tone and sculpt after you
mentioned can you just tell us
what that is and how it works i bet you
guys are really busy during the
quarantine
yeah i mean it's a highly interactive
fitness app it's really a one-stop shop
for all
women that are looking to progress in
their fitness journey
we have two awesome trainers myself and
chrissy cello the owner and founder
and two different training styles
nutrition programs
gym programs home programs and the most
incredible
dialed in most inspiring community i
really think the athletes
that are a part of the total scope
community really make it
special definitely and yeah it's just
i'm really excited to be a part of it
and i it is
super super awesome to be here i love
that first and foremost the girl power
that's behind it all that's so cool and
what are the tone and scope workouts
like what
what workouts do you suggest because at
home workouts are really popular right
now
so you can do anything for my programs
personally or a little bit more sports
performance
um geared towards so um
we're using dumbbells we're using
kettlebells we're using bands we're
using
all things that you can pick up at the
store bring home and really just kind of
use whatever you have around you chairs
sofas whatever we get creative
and we make it work there's obviously
the gym programs that have you throwing
weights around doing all that fun stuff
as well but
the home workouts are definitely super
popular right now
it's to keep everyone nice and safe so
yeah there's literally something for
everybody i love that so we're gonna
have to check out the app to see the
moves but last question here
just some words of encouragement how to
stay motivated in 2021
yeah i think the three main things that
i would
suggest is one start small
i think a lot of people get overwhelmed
with the idea of transforming their
entire lifestyle
from the jump january first also finding
that community
that's going to motivate you inspire you
and push you
like we have at the total scope
community and my most important thing
is mindset right like we need to stop
thinking about
training and working out is something we
have to do instead of instead of
something we get to do right we woke up
today
i agree can she be my trainer
we are not